from blank sheet to fully operational
hospital in less than a fortnight a 21st
century global pandemic requires an
unprecedented response and the NHS 19
gaol is just that we take our resources
from NHS London and we want to be
coordinated from the centre so that they
know the best places to deploy staff and
deploy resources at that point we will
be able to will be ready to receive the
equipment the staff and then the
patients at scale and at pace have the
same standard is occurring back in the
NHS the language used by the Prime
Minister and his aides is marshal talk
of battle lines being drawn so it's
right the military was asked to deliver
this logistical and engineering
masterclass skills honed on the
battlefields of Afghanistan deployed to
the frontline in East London
it's an unseen enemy it's still a battle
and it's and it's still timelines that
you're working to and it's always trying
to get ahead of of the picture you're
trying to get head of the enemy and in
this case you're trying to get over the
virus and so the whole idea about
building up scale and pace is to build a
really fantastic acidity that delivers
save patient care at scale and keeping
head of the battle keeping head of the
virus
the sheer scale of this project and the
speed at which it was delivered is
breathtaking these aren't just
partitioned beds the NHS 19 Gale is a
world's largest critical care unit fully
equipped to deal exclusively with very
sick kovat 19 patients and these
ventilators in short supply nationwide
will soon be plumbed into a four mile
long oxygen tube network you can't help
but be struck by the sheer enormity of
this project this corridor is a
kilometer long
that's row after row after row of
critical care bed capacity and that
gives you an idea of the challenge
facing this country retired medics
airline staff and an army of volunteers
will be the lifeblood of this hospital
trained critical care doctors and nurses
will be sent here from other London
hospitals too they will need the same
safety assurances as they're worried
colleagues elsewhere in the country
we've sent out over 750 million pieces
of protective equipment of this last
fortnight and we're needing to do more
we absolutely need to make sure our
nurses only drives our staff on the
frontline have the protection the 19
Gale is ready to treat its first covert
19 patient that is no cause for
celebration but it will be when she
treats her last Ashish Joshi Sky News